[Music]
what is up everybody it's adamak here
for anime uproar and today we will be
talking about the latest developments in
the seven deadly sins story including
the stunning revelations about the demon
realm and what really happened to
zelgius the crazy thing about these
latest chapters of the manga is that
unlike most conclusions to a story which
tend to just wrap everything up these
new chapters are raising many brand new
questions about the characters and the
world of the seven deadly sins if you're
confused in any way or just wondering
what could happen next do not worry I
will delve deep into everything we know
so far right here in this video but
before we jump into it I want to give a
huge thank you to crunchyroll for
sponsoring this video
crunchyroll is the world's largest
destination for anime and manga and I've
been a paying customer of crunchyroll
for over three years
I use crunchyroll every single day to
watch my favorite anime series like the
latest season of attack on Titan JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure black clover and so
many more a lot of people don't realize
this but crunchyroll also has a manga
section and that's where I go to read
the latest chapters of the seven deadly
sins manga and also attack on Titan and
others I tell him you guys have asked me
where to find the seven deadly sins
manga and as I always say I just read it
right on crunchyroll go to
crunchyroll.com slash anime outro right
now to get crunchyroll premium free for
14 days you'll get unlimited access to
their anime manga and drama titles ad
free in 1080p HD and that includes the
newest anime episodes with professional
subtitles try crunch roll ad free for 14
days by signing up at crunchyroll.com
slash animal pro or just clicked a link
in the description that way you get all
that delicious anime and manga content
including the new chapters of seven
deadly sins you help support the anime
industry and you help support this
channel at the same time it's a win win
win just sign up at crunchyroll.com
slash anime uproar or click that link in
the description quick warning since we
are talking about the latest
developments in the story of the seven
deadly sins this video will contain
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned now chapter
309 starts off with King Bartra
receiving a ring as a birthday present
from
Elizabeth and even though he is
incredibly impressed and pleased with
the gift Margaret and Veronica point out
that it's kind of odd that Elizabeth
would give her father his birthday
present many days before his actual
birthday but of course we find out why
she gave him the present so early later
on in the chapter
meanwhile the sins and their friends are
still trying to come to terms with the
fact that Mellie Otis has to leave the
mortal plane even though she obviously
doesn't want him to go Elizabeth knows
that if none the oldest tries to stay it
will bring trouble the natural disasters
that we saw in the previous chapter were
a clear hint that if Mellie Otis stays
in the mortal plane the balance of power
in the world will be disturbed and there
will be serious consequences before this
chapter we actually weren't sure where
exactly Mellie Otis would have to go
when he leaves the mortal plane and we
speculated about whether he would have
to go to purgatory like his father or
somewhere else like the demon realm
meliodas finally explains that he will
most likely have to go to the demon
world also known as the demon realm
which is where he was born he goes on to
joke about potentially opening the first
tavern there meliodas then decides that
they should take a detour to Edinboro
the setting of the vampires of Edinboro
side manga once there meliodas breaks
the seal that he had placed on gelda 12
years earlier and gelda is finally
released
this is the same gelda who was the lover
of zelgius and for whose sake celtris
refused to kill the vampires after their
betrayal of the demons even though he
was explicitly ordered to execute them
all by his father the demon king however
zelgius was in love with gelda and he
couldn't bring himself to kill her so he
decided to disobey his father's order
and seal the vampires away instead once
she is released and once she sees that
zelgius is not there gelda begins to
despair and she talks about how maybe
she should just give up because there is
no hope for her and zell drous but Mel
Yoda says that zelgius still cares about
her and that in fact she is his only
hope we then learned that gelda isn't
sure whether zelgius truly loves her
because he always seemed primarily
concerned with taking the throne of the
demon king but meliodas explains what we
learned several chapters earlier that
zelgius wanted to become the demon king
so that he could make the demon world
peaceful for all the races of the
underworld
including the demons and the vampires
cell just wanted to become the demon
king so that he could be with gelda
without anyone judging them but while
his ruthless father was still on the
throne he could never do that because
the demon king considered all emotions
especially loved to be a weakness and
the demon king wanted all of his rivals
to be eliminated including the vampires
so zelgius always intended to return to
gelda and free her from the seal he just
wanted to become the demon king before
that happened so that they could
actually be together without worrying
about what his father would do we then
finally learned what happened to Zell
drous after the epic battle with the
demon king well sort of now the Oda says
that zelgius went missing after the
fight and that he feels like a failure
because he could do nothing for his
younger brother and yeah it doesn't help
that we just went several chapters with
zelgius nowhere to be seen and meliodas
didn't even mention him once but at
least now we are finally beginning to
get some answers apparently zelgius is
no longer in this plane the mortal plane
which makes me wonder why Zell drous is
no longer here can tell just go to
purgatory to take out the demon king
once overall or did he get transported
to the demon realm for some reason we
just don't know at this point the only
thing we know is that zelgius is
seemingly alive and even though the
demon realm is finally becoming more
prominent in the story we still have
very limited information about the true
nature of this mysterious world the
demon realm is the birthplace of the
demons and it is said to be home to some
incredibly powerful creatures including
many Enduro it is believed that in the
past the demon realm was extremely
volatile and chaotic but the demon king
managed to conquer all of it and bring
it under his rule however the demon
Kings rule was ruthless and anyone who
was perceived to be a rival or a threat
was destroyed before giving up his claim
to the throne in favor of his older
brother Mele Otis zelgius seems to have
wanted to take control of the demon
King's throne and ruled the demon world
differently from his father he wanted to
bring peace and harmony to all the races
and creatures of this realm and he
wanted to bring an end to hostilities
between the demons and other clans
include
the vampires gelda says that she will go
to zell drous and she proclaims that she
will find him no matter where he is and
even if he's not in this world
before leaving gelda says to Elizabeth
you if anybody know how I feel don't you
and of course we know that Elizabeth is
going through a similar heartbreaking
situation in this very moment the love
of her life Mellie Otis will also have
to leave the mortal plane very soon back
in Lyon as King Bartra summons the sins
and the others in order to tell them
that he wants meliodas to marry
Elizabeth and become the new king this
comes as a surprise to many but the King
assures them that he is serious he is
getting old and everyone respects Mellie
Otis enough to accept him as their king
however when he asks Elizabeth what she
thinks about this she tells her father
that she cannot accept his proposal
because she is planning to go to the
demon world with Mellie Otis so that
they can finally be together in the next
panel we see everyone scream out in
utter shock at this revelation though I
don't really know what is so shocking
about it now that the curse is finally
broken it doesn't surprise me at all
that Elizabeth would be the type of
person to leave with Mellie Otis and
stay with him no matter what even if
that means leaving other people that she
cares about behind after all Mellie Otis
and Elizabeth had spent over 3,000 years
struggling against fate just so they
could be together so it makes perfect
sense to me that Elizabeth would make
this decision nevertheless I have a
suspicion that millio descent Elizabeth
will find a way to stay inside the
mortal plane
thanks to none other than zelgius and
gelda we already know that zelgius
planned to become the next demon king so
that he could govern more justly than
his father and bring peace and harmony
to the demon realm well we are not too
sure why exactly zelgius has gone
missing it isn't too far-fetched to
think that meliodas will make a deal
with zelgius meliodas could agree to
give the demon Kings power to zelgius
thereby passing on the burden of ruling
the demon realm and the other races of
the demon realm to sell dress and gelda
as long as he has gelda zelgius has no
reason to stay in the mortal plane
anyway and we can assume that if he
gives up the demon Kings power to Zell
drous meliodas would probably be able to
stay inside the mortal
my prediction at this point is Emilio's
will pass on the demon king title to his
younger brother and zelgius and gelda
will rule the demon realm while Milly
Otis remains in the mortal plane and
lives a normal life with Elizabeth and
the sins but while this is my prediction
it is by no means certain that this will
happen knock of a suzuki the creator of
the seven deadly sins has definitely
surprised us before and more twists and
turns could still be coming for that
reason we have to wait and see what
happens next in the story let me know
what you guys think do you agree with my
prediction that Mele Otis will pass the
demon Kings power on to zelgius so that
he can remain in the mortal plane while
zelgius rules the demon realm along with
gelda if not what do you think is going
to happen next will Mele Otis and
Elizabeth really be forced to leave
everyone they care about behind or can
we expect a happier ending let me know
down in the comments if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
valve to read the latest chapters of the
seven deadly sins and help this channel
at the same time just sign up at
crunchyroll.com slash anime uproar or
click that link in the description if
you do that you will get access to
crunchyroll premium for free for 14 days
a huge thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for supporting our work
and when i especially thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only gilgamesh
keelon and chubs is the man and another
huge thank you to our the one to your
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ace Maddy Mac
James al Olin Adam Ingrid ah and Ahmad
and at the very pinnacle of
interdimensional greatness the tier
reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to baby Rey the first-ever
disciple of Lord to ego himself if you
guys feel that our content provides
value for you and you want to support
more be sure to check out our patreon
link in the description even donating a
single dollar will give you access to
our anime up for patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate
and until next time see our space
cowboys
[Music]